but first my brain dump
it's a stunning seismic bombshell that
sends shockwaves across america and
indeed the rest of the world an
unprecedented leak from the u.s supreme
court shows that america's most powerful
judges are about to overturn roe versus
wade that's the landmark law which has
effectively legalized abortion in the
united states for the past 50 years
it's easy to forget when you live in a
country where abortion is legal and a
long accepted part of society in america
this remains a highly charged emotional
debate that divides people like almost
nothing else protesters from both sides
immediately descended on the court
[Music]
overturned then individual states in
america will be free to set the rules
and almost half of those states are
expected to move swiftly to ban abortion
if they can already abortion laws in the
united states are a complete mess
pro-life states have for years made it
as difficult as possible to get an
abortion without themselves breaking the
law a woman who chooses to have an
abortion in missouri for example a state
with a population of six million people
only has one clinic to go to she'll have
to wait 72 hours before signing consent
and having the procedure the doctor is
then compelled by law to warn her that
life begins at conception but literally
just a few miles away in illinois the
neighboring state the same woman can
choose from dozens of clinics and have
the procedure done on the same day so
you end up with this wretched confusing
patchwork of rules and so-called
abortion refugees traveling across state
lines at least those women who can
afford to do that undoing roe vs wade
will most definitely directly harm the
poorest women in u.s society who want an
abortion now i'm not an american so i
have no vote or say of what laws
americans have but i'm entitled to my
opinion and i believe women should be
free to choose what they do with their
bodies just as we men are more
importantly the majority of americans
agree with me and support roe versus
wade almost two-thirds of them in fact
just 27 percent say it should be
scrapped
i'm pro-voice on pro-choice it seems to
me a dangerous moment for american
democracy when the supreme court goes
against the will of the majority of its
people on a matter of such personal
freedom
[Music]
well is that million dollar question
again isn't it the treacherous puzzler
that's frazzling even the world's
biggest brains what is it is it what's
dark matter nope not that one how big is
the universe
nope
when did life start
not even that one it's this
what is a woman
yes really
scottish nationalist leader nicholas
sturgeon has led his politician to be
tied in not to petrified panic by this
completely innocuous question asked by
the times to define a woman she said
i'm not going to i'm just not going to
get into this debate at a level that's
simplified and has lurid headlines trans
people are amongst possibly the most
stigmatized and discriminated against
minorities in our society
they have to say nicola
it's not a debate
it's literally a word that's a very
simple meaning
it's not nothing to do with trans rights
it's entirely possible to support equal
rights for trans people as i do and
answer this simple question with a
simple answer
just check any dictionary in the world
and you'll find that a woman is defined
as an adult human female that's it
that's the answer
and when you don't answer it like that
you do women and women's rights such a
massive disservice on a day when
american women are on the verge of
losing the right to decide what to
legally do with their bodies that
definition has never been more vital or
important
it's now 15 years since british toddler
madeleine mccann was snatched from her
bedroom during a family holiday in
portugal as her parents had dinner 50
yards away with friends madeline's body
has never been found she may still be
alive nobody knows no one's been charged
over her disappearance very few child
abduction stories grip the world quite
like this one it made global headlines
amid a desperate international search to
find her and to this day she's regularly
planted across the front pages with even
the smallest of updates from police
inquiries
at the center of all this are her
devastated parents kate and jerry mccann
now i've interviewed them several times
i've always been struck by both the
terrible grief they feel for what
happened to the little girl and the
inevitable regret that their actions may
have contributed to her disappearance
you're intelligent people and you were
certainly good parents there's no one's
questioning that from all accounts we've
all heard it's just when you have people
coming in and off a street like that and
it's not your home and it's not really
secure
again i mean i think it is back to the
safety issue we did not perceive an
element of threat and
child abduction is so rare why would you
have ever have thought that someone was
going to get into an apartment and steal
your child it just didn't enter their
head if it had
it wouldn't have happened and
all these questions day in day out why
how why
and i can only you know say to myself
kate you felt really safe and i know how
much i love my children and there's no
way i'd have taken a risk
they don't need anyone to tell them they
shouldn't have left madeline alone with
her young siblings that night however
safe it may have seemed in the resort
they have to live with that decision
every day they must eat away at their
souls but there's not a parent alive who
hasn't lost sight of a child for a few
moments or longer and felt that
sickening dread that the mccanns have
now had for 15 years it happened to me
once i lost one of my sons for 30
minutes near a running creek i'll never
forget the desperate despair that swept
over me all the unbridled joy when he
was found safe
the mccanns only had the despair
and to compound their misery vile trolls
bombard them with abuse every time
madeleine's name gets mentioned in the
media again even falsely and
disgracefully accusing them of being
involved in her death
to pour such vicious fuel on the endless
torment is the most disgusting form of
human callousness
on this 15th anniversary of her
disappearance i pray that one day the
mccanns get the closure about madeleine
that they crave
who knows maybe she's still alive god
that would be an amazing thing
but until then if you have nothing
compassionate to say about the mccanns
just shut up
as war rages in europe a deadly pandemic
continues to wreak havoc and ruin its
inflation these families living in fear
of being able to pay their next bill
well what better time for an elitist
ball and a pouting procession of our
most pampered prima donna celebrities
the annual met gala in new york last
night featured a gilded glamour dress
code apparently paying homage with no
sense of irony to america's era of
economic ascent this is lines for food
banks are through the roof you couldn't
make it up this might just have been the
most tone-deaf self-indulgent
narcissistic orgy of vain glorious
nonsense in recent celebrity history
stars bedecting garish and in many cases
absolutely hideous gowns costing tens of
thousands of dollars parading the red
carpet apparently utterly oblivious to
the suffering going on in the world
outside them the main gala used to be
about the biggest and most talented
stars of entertainment beyonce lady gaga
rihanna strutting down that carpet this
year was a
who's who of who cares
let's take a look at some of them
here's emily radachowski
the model
only shocking because it's the first
time i've seen her in clothes for about
three years
brooklyn beckham what's he doing there
his only claim to fame is his dad used
to kick a football around
hillary clinton she was described by
variety magazine as looking regal regal
the only regal thing about what she was
wearing is it closely resembles the
curtains i saw at buckingham palace when
i went to meet the queen
as for kylie jenner apparently eight
people had to get her into this meringue
wedding dress and why was she wearing a
wedding dress
but the single most irritating moment of
the night came from well appropriately
the single most irritating person
kylie's big sister billionaire irritant
kim kardashian who turned up wearing
marilyn monroe's iconic nude-colored
happy birthday mr president dress the
one that marilyn wore when she sang to
jfk in has six thousand hand-sewn
crystals woven into it and was sold a
few years ago for five million dollars
at auction kim might as well have pulled
the maria antoinette when she was at it
had the words let the meat cake etched
into her surgically enhanced backside
miss kardashian said she had to lose 16
pounds in three weeks to squeeze into my
dress and she is forever grateful for
the moment
i'm also forever grateful that i wasn't
there to risk my spleen spontaneously
erupting over this disgusting
desecration of one of the most famous
and classiest items of clothing in
hollywood history paul marilyn must be
turning in her grave and speaking of
grey's not a more serious point what a
slap in the face this all was to those
who've lost loved ones to covet bombs
and poverty this year